[Music]
hey everyone welcome to eat cheese
Facebook page on Jenny directo I'm
Ashley crosses close to the end of a
warranty so morsi's in the beginning of
a hotter weekend you got a bit of a gain
of the end it's been a long road to the
Academy Awards me retire but we are here
to break down what to expect from
Sunday's big award show and let me tell
you we've done our homework right we
watched a lot oh my gosh I can I just
say really quickly I'm so proud of you
right now we're finally watching lion-o
like there's a couple what's on the list
that I need to get to in line with one
of them but you guys we're in for a
really big award show with some huge
racist we're going to break these down
and please don't let us do all the
talking if you disagree with us and if
your route if we're so in particular let
us know in the comments section below
will call you out but we also want to
hear from you guys will let us know okay
yes you did right in all right the
biggest races you guys let's kick off
with Best Actor Best Actor okay Casey
Affleck has been winning a lot of season
so a lot of people are predicting him
but I don't know what do you think well
I saw both films full
manchester-by-the-sea and of course I'm
talking about Denzel Washington and
senses because Casey is the presumed
frontrunner however Denzel is really
giving him a run for his money first of
all let's not like Denzel Washington so
he's good in everything right but this
is such a tour de force performance and
I know he's one before but he is on the
heels of Casey in my opinion and I could
see in what world this would be his to
lose what about Ryan Gosling do you not
think he's the front-runner I don't know
brian is a front-runner I don't I mean a
lot lala land of course got a lot of
love it's going in with 14 nominations I
don't think this is the category that
they will take it I mean it's time it's
between Casey who gave a really
emotional and poignant performance
versus Denzel who's a Academy favorite
and like I said he just really like
blazes through that screen my money's on
denso okay I was gonna pay us here I was
gonna ask you hear you're going for it
I'm gonna say Denzel as well don't you
think oh yes Denzel of course beat him
at the sag awards too so I think he does
have a a little bit more of an edge come
he was so shocked saying how it dude
keep it cold over here so Washington
even said he was like you know the young
guys been winning all these and he
details backstage actually when we were
there
that he was talking about Casey so that
would be a race to watch but my money's
on dead zone okay that's accurate whoo I
have a lot to say you go first okay okay
well emma stone has been winning a lot
or she's been kind of the darling of
this award season i absolutely love her
but it has been bumming me out a little
bit that natalie portman hasn't gotten
enough recognition for her role in
Jackie because she's obviously playing
Jackie Kennedy and she is amazing I mean
if you watch an interview with Jackie
Kennedy and then you watch this film
it's almost uncanny I mean it's amazing
and I want to see I want to see Natalie
Portman win I really do and there's no
denying it like i mean the the proof is
right there she's in the entire felt
like that film is now he's right you
know to me yeah that's her so I could I
would like to see her also accept
another Oscar pregnant that would be
kind of cool but come on Emma Stone aye
he's been on a hot streak like you
mentioned she picked up the BAFTA
recently the SAG wash as the Golden
Globe um so I don't know I have a
feeling it's gonna be Emma I don't know
I know I know I think and and not that
Emma wouldn't deserve it she's great I
just really want some rescue mission for
natalie portman so I'm gonna go with her
I'm gonna go dark horse natalie portman
I mean what if honestly there's like the
biggest surprise tonight like it is
about who pair just like takes it away
from Emma and natalie portman happen
it's happenin oh yeah I've been at the
golden girl yeah you're totally right
yeah no that would be a fun race to
watch too but you're going Portman I'm
going apartment i'm going stone how
would you sum one put money on it yes
lunch lunch best supporting actor okay
we love this category because there's
two particular actors either rooting for
this entire you have like right yeah
both so deserving by the way in their
mascot wind entire course we've talked
to both of them like I'm gonna start
I've been rooting this entire Ward
season former Herschel ollie in
moonlight you know there's a lot of
argument about how the fact he's not in
a lot of it however when he and I'm not
trying to spoil anything but you know he
is not in a most of the movie but his
presence is felt like there's a
references character a lot I mean
honestly rehearsal I you know you're my
dude and he just like moved me so much
in that performance and of course he's
it's been a banner year for him
and he just had a kid yesterday we
learned that the news is up on each
online.com right now he had a kid it's a
big year for him and I would love for
him to just like close out the year with
that cherry on top of an amazing sunday
and take home that Oscar gold on Sunday
I mean I think that really seems to be
in the bag but I am going to say that I
love death death patel in lyon i mean
when i watched that film that his
performance stuck with me for days weeks
months at this point i mean i still i
mean i know you watched it the other day
i thought i could not stop thinking
about it I don't know if he felt that
way but I thought his performance was so
amazing he's obviously playing a real
life persons I don't know there's just
so much in that role and the emotion in
the last you know 10 minutes of that
movie I just thought your rest and i
will say that dev and i'm going to MIT
it right here live on facebook that made
me cry when I watched that rehearsal it
did not not that's like any prerequisite
to win an Oscar gotta cry but I'm just
saying like I could see what world dev
would all of a sudden just sweep in and
swoop in and grab that trophy especially
up he be Alma her Sheila at the BAFTAs
and the Raptor Wars and I but I see
Benny over here riding rehearsal or bus
I'm with you brother for sure and then
we've got Andrew Garfield did really
good job super underrated I mean haxel
rich his performance in that movie is
really really great and that his role
specifically hasn't gotten a ton of love
I mean we definitely heard a lot about
the movie and Mel get some stretching
job but Andrew Garfield that movie is so
good so many good performances you hear
like I were you know we're only talking
about two per category but like mad
these people are in BO nomination oh my
gosh is one of them for absolutely movie
right along the best supporting actress
I mean I think this is the log I mean
there is no doubt about it that viola
davis incenses was incredible she's
incredible and everything but she's also
swept almost every award this season and
I'd be surprised if it did not go to her
like I need that first addicted to lose
I agree at the same time nobody else in
this category would be a bad like I
wouldn't be disappointed if anybody else
in this category one I mean naomie
harris and moonlight a co-payment in
Lyon Octavia Spencer the shell was I
mean they're all amazing performances
the idea
great a file Davis probably knew me and
she has actually addressed this with us
and this whole the whole media run of
the award season she has talked about
how it's almost unnerving how people
keep tying or shoots a front runner
right because I'm appeared if you don't
wish she said like if you don't win a
game this looks that much more because
we all said that she's a runner but I
mean like I said it's kind of I feel
like this is the lock and it would be a
pretty amazing story you know she won
the Tony for this same role when it was
on Broadway so and it would be her first
win she's been nominated three times and
like I think it's time to give viola
davis a Oscar I need that speech I need
that moment but I think if we're seeing
that I don't know you know it might be a
very political Oscars and I'm not saying
she'll be exempt from that but we'll get
a very moving speech that were gonna be
quotin for the rest of the year so yes
yes i do that little bit need it best
picture a little big one I mean who you
rooting for o lion but no honestly lion
was my favorite movie dear I've said
that out loud so many times do I think
it's going to win best picture no I
really don't I think it's um I think it
for me while I land I mean I think I
think that's been kind of the darling of
yours easily we said that a million
times but I do think it's gonna be lala
land but it could also be moonlight
right exactly but they're saying that
it's between lala land and moonlight and
to be fair like to your point you know
lala land really has been the darling
all awards season and I think it's
really rare when you get that many
nominations 14 that you don't win best
picture because I believe it tied with
Titanic and All About Eve who all up
with 14 nominations and those two
pictures one the big ward so I'd be
surprised if lala land didn't win but
you know my heart of hearts I really
loved moonlight is to see what we love
an underdog over here's what we want to
see what it's so true but ya know I'd be
surprised if long it didn't take it and
in that same vein best director is
probably between those two directors as
well as Damon shaselle and Barry Jenkins
Daniels shaselle I know my kimchi I'm
tonight hahaha would be the youngest
winner yes which I mean doesn't eat when
you when I watch him I'm like that's
like that was all of us but a little
film nerd you
who's like had this crazy outlandish
idea for a movie and then made it happen
and got ryan gosling and emma stone to
started it yeah I mean in this race i'm
actually rooting for Damien I agree yeah
I do agree but you know some of those
happen Myra so incredible come on and of
course if Jenkins wins he will be the
first african-american winner to invest
director which is also a pretty amazing
feat so hats off to both those
filmmakers valerian is like so awesome
what are you guys talking about over
here Raya says moonlight has her vote
yep and Denzel if he wins again yes
thank you for reminding us this will be
his second war for that fences role
Denzel inviolable played those roles on
Broadway won the Tony and if you guys
haven't seen fences those two were
freaking amazing you won't see to better
performances this year so I'm going for
those two for sure what would it be
graces those are the big races but we
can also have to talk about the fashion
because it's the Academy Awards that's
where people really turn it out you know
and it's where a lot of fashion houses
and designers are like just chomping at
the bit to get us start to wear one of
their they're designed on the Red Cloud
my gosh just wasn't a lifetime kind of
like event you know what I mean I was
literally just did an interview with
rosanna before I got here and he's
presenting and he was like yep I got my
things picked out but luckily someone
else is doing it for me oh yeah he's got
to rip it out ready to go but some
people we want to do that you wanted
yeah who are you looking forward to
seeing because honestly natalie
portman's like pregnancy fashion that's
like one I'm kind of looking forward to
because oh right it's been 80 I had a
hot cakes did you like the Golden Globes
look we're looking at right I like that
yeah absolutely like that she's really
pregnant too so it's like that they're
really bad girl they're really trying to
dress that bump but wish she was
pregnant the last time she was at her
when she won the Oscar I thought that
was an amazing look and so I'm really
excited to see what they put her in a I
think we have another look from her
dress after sagol all this is someone I
didn't want you know like this one no
got a little matronly right it was just
yeah it was a lot of fabric haha want
you to pregnant lady you know it can be
comfortable i think but her hair makeup
so is on point yes yes so so except for
looks like for Naomi Harris a moonlight
she's in crashing out Oh Mike Tyson
crossing it if she doesn't win the Oscar
I think she'll win best dress because
she has been so amazing on the record
yeah look at that oh oh my god the
Golden Globes and I'm at the sag awards
mean I know rice slay me she's still
gorgeous in person to I've talked to her
a couple times in swartz he didn't she's
so good but of course Emma Stone another
fashion darling you know we were
recapping fashion from the Golden Globes
I think and um somebody was saying i
want to say with Courtney was saying
that i'ma turn same kind of wearing it
safe to season may be stated I said that
but I really want to see yeah i agree i
want to fear do something daring for
after maybe she's saving it like maybe
she's saving it for this night becomes a
nice the big nights the big award like
she ever I'm gonna go that's not playing
that's good that's really pretty no but
I know what they mean by that like maybe
we'll see a pop of color you know some
trends were expecting seeking a pop of
color pop of color I'll miss viola z
look at that yellow blah blah boom yes
this is a woman who plays to her skin
tone she said that to us actually about
the SAG Awards you know I want something
to highlight me in my glow and I'm like
you shine on girl but the viral addition
I'm also very excited about Nicole
Kidman the whole Kimmy can never do any
wrong oh yes what she'd get the parrot
at one time I love that oh look at that
that quote pretty look at that with her
like her skin tone she just knows how to
cover we talking to the make up for it
and everything there it is there's the
parents that Sony to take summer I loved
that I did to actually see we need to
see more of that at the Academy Awards I
think you know yes shaken up a little
folks up talking about how Nicole Kidman
in line like she needed those wigs
because she's just so beautiful and it's
kind of distracting like she said you
needed to kind of suspend your disbelief
think you got a ton of town girls I
throw in a curly willow he's going to
believe you're comin I love but you guys
moving on to the actual telecast I mean
we're in for a treat with a lot of
amazing performances by some people who
could make history if they win Best
Original Song lin-manuel Miranda he is
nominated for mallanna for best original
song and he could become and eat got if
he wins Emmy Grammy Oscar Tony yes and
he will be the youngest ever if that
happens he's there
seven years old the owner Robert Lopez
who won for frozen was 38 years old I
believe so yes is manning it the fastest
right to be coming he got I think he
would he would have been doing it in
nine years so if he wins it he's
collected all those trophies within nine
years in nine years epic I mean if
there's anyone who deserve into that
it's Lindeman well and talk about a hot
streak like coming off hamilton I think
he even said he was writing some of
these songs while he was still doing
Hamilton's yeah so balancing those two
two completely different worlds but also
creating works bodies are work that
people are just obsessed with like we
love tube Lana oh my gosh how many times
have you seen it no I only seen it once
oh my soft three times they got really
sweet and those songs are so damn cat I
listened to the soundtrack not stop it's
so good but you know we actually talked
to lynn about the it's so funny you
talked about how busy he was because i
was i was with him last night at the
oscar wilde awards which is JJ abrams
event celebrating people of irish
heritage and I was like I have so much
to ask about like do you have 25 minutes
for me to ask you then like Mary Poppins
Disney oscars in hamilton and but anyway
I did talk to him last night and he is
performing at the Oscars so I'm going to
give you a little peek of what he had to
say last night moving right yeah do you
can you look slightly well we're
performing how far I'll go okay yeah my
level of involvement is a secret okay
okay you're welcome what's he gonna do
yeah I know even rehearsing I mean no we
rehearse for the first time together
tomorrow so I'm really excited oh my god
there's my nose but yes they are
rehearsing possibly right now and you
know he doesn't sing that song in the
film oh I'm really excited to see what
his level of involvement is going to be
because he kind of teased he was like
I'm in it obvious kind of like peeing
her up I don't know I'm really hoping
those Oscars producers also don't hold
back and make it like a epic set to you
could come on we need the water the
flowers right we're on that ship like
I'm looking for that performance for
sure I mean he has some stiff
competition though and a couple of music
stars justin timberlake but also one
John Legend him I you know John measured
he might have heard of him he was of
course in la-la land this year
and he sing a couple songs however he is
subbing in this he said been in on
sunday for emma stone and ryan gosling
who solos in la-la land the songs got
nominated but they're not performing and
I actually talked to John at the nwacc p
image awards about the performance he
teased a little bit and also explain why
he's the one to do it and not ryan and
emma take a look yeah he does use it
Rosa nobody so I think you're good job
talk to us about this big Oscar
performance you're performing a la la
land medley right yes we're so excited
about that I'm proud to be part of the
film and I think mm Ryan wanted to focus
on you know join enjoying the night so
they put me to work well you're no
stranger to the Oscar stage right what
do you have your up your sleep of this
performance well we want to honor the
songs you know they're beautiful songs
went by Justin her within a team and
we're so proud of the film and the score
and all the songs that were part of it
that we want to celebrate that and I
thought you got the Grammy feel good on
him by the way to step in and do that
because Ryan and Mike y'all suck what I
was so ready for you guys to perform at
the Oscars but I don't same as a fan I
like wanted to see you guys perform
those like that by the way you don't
suck you're actually of me oh Jenny
shade I really want to see the performs
as always I also understand like the
pressure and the fact that you're also
nominated like you press but that's a
lot going into one night and I don't
feel like I don't want to get drunk and
sit down and like hang out and not have
to get on stage for got enough stress to
worry about know for the record big fans
of ryan and emma is not a phase of it
but of course John Legend is John Legend
he's used to performing he performed at
the Oscars when he won for glory so that
would be an exciting exciting
performance Thank You Benny I just you
know I just wanted to see that happen I
agree um you know the one thing people
are talking about too is the in memoriam
because of course we lost so many huge
huge stars and a lot of actors and so
you know expect something really sad it
was just announced by the producers
yesterday by Sara Bareilles will be
performing the song which I mean she's
gonna make a crab thing as we absolutely
amazing voice and like you said he has
so many huge losses this year I mean
got mascotas listened a little bit yeah
I know right howdy-do Prince Carrie
Fisher Debbie Reynolds in Wilder Mary
Tyler Moore John Hurt like so many
people how many people I to be a long
segment it's pretty a long segment is
gonna be really sad and yeah I but you
know paint Amish and honoring all those
stars i think is so fitting especially
right now because like we lost so many
artists and so many great bodies of work
so look forward to that and i will say
that host Jimmy Kimmel has even made
light of it saying it might be the
longest segment of the actual telecast
you know we actually caught up with him
yesterday and all that is actually on
each online but he is teasing a lot of
fun stuff including this rivalry with
Matt Damon I mean okay yeah they have
long been rivals playing it up for on
Jimmy Kimmel Live and with press up so
expect and matt damon is a producer on
manchester-by-the-sea so he will be in
the audience i'm looking forward to a
little Matt versus Jimmy little thing on
sunday how about you oh absolutely bring
it though you should be pretty fun about
that felt like I said he'd heard of
something he did I don't know if we put
it up your face I know right here are
some things worse we did something to
that Damon but I don't over a lot of me
up so I'm looking back at that and also
his a family affair believe I cuz his
wife apparently is one of the writers to
for the [ __ ] for Jimmy Kimmel Live balls
for the Oscars and so I'm looking
forward to hopefully some roasting on
his part but that would be a lot of fun
and we'll see it all go down on Oscar
Sunday absolutely began to someone yes
ad says I hope that by Viola Davis wins
she was a wonderful yes garden says John
Legend brings life always right and push
will get chrissy teigen there too so
they both bring life i'm not a chrissy
teigen red carpet moment i love it laura
say mu my another incredible movie
rehearse lolly also deserves an Oscar I
couldn't agree with you more there girl
but we'll have to find out on Sunday for
the big show you guys there's alive on
ABC around five-thirty live
coast-to-coast actually and we'll be
holding it down here tracking every move
in fact you guys will have another
oscars preview sunday right before the
actual telecast and then another one
after recapping all the biggest moments
of speeches a sheet covering it like
you're gonna be in every life I think I
think so you know if you like this
keep coming back for more exactly
there's so much more tonight we're
actually hosting the the Entertainment
Tonight Show from the Oscars red carpet
tonight so check your local listing but
guys we got a lot more coming ETonline
your way so stick with us for all your
oscars goodness and we're going to take
a nap before that they picture where it
exactly thanks for joining us 55
[Music]
you